من يتلطف بالطين اكثر يصبح اكثرهم سعاده
وتفاؤلا ومن يساعد صديقه بكميات اكبر من
الطين يقه ذلك من الشرور والاتام عرقيه
والصينيه التلطيخ بالطين لطرد الارواح
الشريره
[موسيقى]
في مقاطعه كان جوان بجنوب غرب الصين
وبالقرب من الحدود مع ميانمار يجتمع كلها
هؤلاء الناس من السكان المحليين وبعض
السائحين من اجل انغماس في الطين كرنفال
مبهج بالنسبه لهم يبعث فيهم روح الامل
والتفاؤل والعجيب ان منطلقها اكثر بالطين
يصبح فيهم الاكثر سعاده لكن هذا الطين ليس
كالطين المعروف لنا المكون من تراب ومياه
بل انه نوع خاص يدعى تطينو نيانغ بولو
بلغه قبيله والصينيه وهو مصنوع من بعض
المستخلصات النباتيه في الاونه الاخيره
اصبح هذا الحدث نافذه للاجانب للتعرف على
المجتمع بالتاريخ الطويل فعرقيه ولها
تاريخ ممتد في الصين وتعرف بتقاليدها
ومهرجاناتها الغريبه
مجموعه عرقيه معترفا بها رسميا في الصين
والتي لا يمكن العثور عليها الا في مقاطعه
يونان وهم احفاد شعبي ويبلغ عددهم حاليا
نحو نصف مليون نسمه
تقاليدهم الغريبه صنعت منهم اسطوره رمزيه
في الصين فعند غضبهم مثلا او عند الخلاف
مع قريه مجاوره يقومون بشيء غريب جدا
يرسلون لهم الفلفل الحار للتعبير عن سخطهم
وانزعاجهم اما في حاله رضاهم فيرسلون قصب
السكري والملح في دلاله على امتنانهم
بصداقتهم مع تلك القريه او القبيله ومحصول
الارز هناك لا غنى عنه فهو شغلهم الشاغل
طوال حياتهم لدرجه انهم يتقربون الى
الهتهم بقرارنا من اللحم والارز
يستخدم شعب يونان واللحوم والارز كقربان
لاله الارز لجني حصاد جيد مهرجان الارز هو
مهرجان تقليدي لعرقيه وعد يتم الاحتفال به
لمده ثلاثه ايام هي منتصف الخريف تقريبا
في الاصل كانت لعرقيه ومعتقدات دينيه
وثنيه تتمحور حول طقوس التضحيه بالدم فقد
كان للقرى معالج روحي واحد
يعالجنه بطريقه تقليديه فيقوم مع اهل
المريض بالتضحيه بدجاجه او جاموس او حيوان
اكبر كل حسب حجم البلاء وفقا للاسطوره
المحليه اما اليوم فربما اكثر ما يميزهم
هو هذا المهرجان الغريب حيث السباحه في
الطين
[موسيقى]